just 24 hours after his explosive
interview aired here on cbs this morning
court officers in chicago arrested him
yesterday after hearing over unpaid
child support bills
authorities say that kelly will stay in
jail until he comes up with more than
161 thousand dollars
that he owes his three children this
morning in a portion of the interview
that you haven't heard we actually
talked to r kelly
for over 80 minutes the r b singer says
he has little money left
your income it was reported that your
income was very high
hundreds of millions of dollars we'll
say that because i don't want to get
hung up on that that's one room i wish
that was true
and yet when you were in jail last week
the bond was a hundred thousand dollars
and they said r kelly couldn't even
afford to get himself out of jail
that a friend had to come and bail you
out of jail what is your financial
situation if you don't mind
saying here's the deal so many people
have been stealing my money
was connected to my account i went
into i went by myself for the first time
to uh bank of america didn't know what i
was doing
didn't know what the hell was going on
when did you do that
first time by yourself about three weeks
ago to a month
three weeks ago was the first time you
went to bank america by yourself
by myself because i was so tired
of not knowing where my money was
what my publishing is isn't that on you
then huh
isn't that on you a lot of it's only
that you didn't know
where your money is a lot of it's on me
and people say he doesn't have money
because he had to pay so much
in settlements what do you say about
that according to court documents kelly
settled three lawsuits with women who
allege they were minors
when he had sex with them but kelly says
what really caused him is the people
who had access to his bank account
something he found out
from a bank teller i had like 350
000 in the bank
and i told her look take that
i want gonna start a new account and and
that's the way it is
right so she said okay it's gonna take
six to seven business days
to clear does that make sense yeah the
day after the trip to the bank
kelly was indicted on ten counts of
aggravated criminal sexual
abuse he says he was unable to access
his bank account to make bail
now he's back in jail for the separate
child support case
something he became emotional about
during our interview
how can i pay child support how
if my ex-wife is destroying my name
and i can't work how can i work
how can i get paid how can i take care
of my kids
how your ex-wife use your common sense
your ex-wife says she abused her robert
13
13 years
being married i flew in
on a helicopter
i flew in on a helicopter
yes can somebody give us some fusion i
don't want to test him
i believe look man look
i'm telling y'all i flew in on a
helicopter
with a damn puppy and i
proposed to drill whom i was in love
with
and told her hey look
i make mistakes i'm not perfect we got
married okay we had three beautiful kids
not once have i ever had a domestic
violence call at the house and all this
than the other
it never happened okay but in a lifetime
docu-series surviving r kelly
his ex-wife andrea described a
tumultuous and sometimes
dangerous relationship and i went to the
national
domestic violence awareness hotline and
there are 17 questions
there was only two things on that list
that robert hadn't done to me
and that's when it became real to me
like
to you being abused is andrea not
telling the truth when she said she was
abused by you
is she not telling the truth absolutely
she's not telling the truth
i love her to death no i have nothing
against her still
that is my kid's mother she's making
that up that's one
thing why is she making that up robert
i'm not disrespecting her by saying
she's not telling the truth
i'm just being honest somebody sent me
something on my phone and said that
i hope tired her i don't know how to hug
that people
what would i all do my kids just listen
to this all of these nurses and i ain't
been
spending no time with them this is real
this is not a lie what kind of woman
will tear down a
dad who's trying to have a relationship
with their kids you know how many kids
need a relationship with their father
what is your relationship with you oh my
god
what is your relationship with your
children
zero zero but i know my kids love me
and i'm in love with my kids i love my
kids
in january kelly's oldest child who is
now 20 years old wrote in an instagram
post
that she and her two siblings have not
had a relationship with their father for
years
we reached out to andrea kelly for
comment on r kelly's allegations but her
representatives say
they do not have any statements at this
time you know i was there and it was
disturbing it's even more disturbing to
see it on video
i even think this is more disturbing
than what we saw yesterday um
you know you talked about him being sort
of on the verge of of something but the
volatility
that i saw there the intensity um what
looked like lying about his past too
it's it was it was disturbing to watch
yeah when you contrast what he said
about his wife and then what you heard
from her in that docu-series you just
can't make sense of it no